yes 30 years after the Hillsborough
disaster in which 96 football fans lost
their lives the judge
so Peter Openshaw here at Preston Crown
Court has decided that the match
commander on the day a chief
superintendent David duckenfield should
face a retrial on a charge of gross
negligence manslaughter there's very
little for legal reasons that we can add
to that at the moment other than to say
that this retrial will take place on the
7th of October also here at Preston
Crown Court and it will be heard by the
same judge so Peter Openshaw the reason
that David duckenfield faces a charge of
gross negligence manslaughter against 95
of the fans and not 96 is that the last
one
Tony bland died more than a year and a
day after the disaster and according to
the law at the time that could not be
included in any subsequent charges so
David duckenfield who is now 74 and
lives in Dorset will return to Preston
Crown Court in October to face the
retrial in front of a jury and Michael
is there any other outstanding legal
business legal cases in connection to
Hillsborough still there is another
hearing that was due to take place later
this year involving a solicitor and a
former police officer we can't say much
about that either but that has now been
moved back to next year ostensibly to
make way for the trial of David
duckenfield here at Preston Crown Court
the judge said in delivering his
decision this morning that he had
refused the application by mr.
duckenfield barristers to stay the
retrial that is to stop it
in effect the hearing here at Preston
Crown Court this morning was relayed to
a group of bereaved family members in
Liverpool
who apparently cheered shouted and
clenched their fists when they heard the
outcome